je reviens dans 2 minutes j'ai une
droite à lui mettre
sorti les vieilles chansons en français
non je savais même pas que ça existait
[Musique]
pas vraiment là vous êtes très très
bronzé là oui des petits souvenirs de
vacances alors les appartenaient l'une
des 8 familles ducal de France du jeudi
pour ceux qui savent pas c'est un titre
héréditaire le premier duc de
Clermont-Tonnerre ça date de 1100
et alors vous êtes princesse aussi
mais ça série de princesse ou non oui
parce que celui-là est d'origine romain
germanique du 16e siècle donc les femmes
ont le droit de porter des titres de
princesses puisque ce n'est pas un titre
français mais quand vous avez eu 18 ans
vos frères et soeurs ont le droit de
s'appeler princesse
mon frère c'était prêt soyons clairs
et pourquoi pas vous
non non on l'a mais vous l'avez à la
naissance et moi j'étais un petit peu le
petit canard je dirais gris clair de la
famille
depuis je garde les couleurs en hommage
et voilà donc mes parents m'ont dit non
tu fais trop de bêtises pour qu'on
a demandé de changer de nom quand même
ah non non mais j'ai le droit à tout
mais il trouvait que pour 18 ans je
faisais pas assez sérieux c'est vrai que
le fait de descendre d'une famille
titrée sous le Saint Empire romain
germanique ça vous autorise à rentrer
dans Saint-Pierre à cheval
les armes des Clermont tonnerre c'est
deux clés de Saint-Pierre vous les avez
tatoués non c'est vrai ça non c'est vrai
on peut pas regarder impossible
[Applaudissements]
votre père donc le duc de
Clermont-Tonnerre était
lieutenant-colonel de parachutiste
alors avec ça voilà contre de Gaulle oui
pour que l'Algérie reste française
exactement
non mais votre père
[Musique]
j'étais celle qui lui ressemblait le
plus il aimait bien faire des bêtises et
j'aimais bien en faire aussi
le foot c'est une grosse bêtise quand
même
des rapports plutôt conflictuels avec
votre mère non
non
ma mère
je suis pas assez classique mais c'est
tout
des problèmes de succession sur le
château quand même
c'est pas grave
[Rires]
l'a repris après deux ans de procédure
quand même lorsque
vos parents j'ai des problèmes entre eux
parce que à un moment votre père lui
interdit de s'appeler duchesse est-ce
qu'il pouvait lui interdire de s'appeler
duchesse
alors là je vais vous dire il faudrait
faire venir un avocat et
non non
je suis pas très bonne mais vous avez le
côté religieux et après vous avez la loi
française donc ça dépend si vous gardez
le côté religieux votre femme reste
éternellement votre femme pas que vous
le dire
elle était quand même assez dure avec
vous c'est vrai qu'elle vous corriger la
cravache mais normal quand elle a un
petit diable il faut le corriger
quelqu'un
est-ce que j'ai l'air traumatisé
pas du
golfate
je vais te dire un moment donné elle a
hésité à se mettre au baseball
ils ont 11 ans
c'est le frère de
ça va Marshall mon petit frère a 11 ans
il a déjà fait 9 pensions et c'est quand
même trouvé un champion avant moi on
finira avec Jean-Claude J3
de Jérusalem et la maison française et
on vous demande de baisser les yeux
quand vous croisiez ce qu'ils appelez un
péché passant c'est ça mais je trouve ça
génial
je vais t'expliquer quand il y avait des
garçons parce que de temps en temps on
avait un parc et alors on faisait le
grand tour et il y a des chemins
communaux où tu peux pas empêcher et
n'importe qui de se balader donc il y
avait des garçons qui guettaient nous on
y allait évidemment
bah évidemment et les bonnes soeurs
disaient mesdemoiselles baissez les yeux
le péchez passe donc vous travaillez
dans la mode
et là quand vous décidez d'aller
travailler dans la mode votre famille
vous dit tu sais qu'il y a des drogués
et des dans ce métier il le savait
comment
c'était l'image c'était l'image qu'ils
avaient de la mode et c'était quand tu
pars dans le milieu de la mode c'est
vrai que les filles soient des robes un
peu spéciales à l'originale pas très
couverte et pour eux c'était oui c'était
pas très sérieux et puis quand vous avez
le milieu gay pour eux c'est voilà c'est
la drogue voilà aujourd'hui donc vous
faites des RP vous avez des relations
publiques de communication où je suis
pas seulement des RP heureusement et à
dire
communications de parfum de fringues de
films marketing de boîte sur toute la
communication quand vous invitez des
stars dans une soirée comme ça vous les
payez combien
je n'ai jamais sorti un franc pour payer
qui que ce soit jamais mais pourquoi ils
viennent les gens comme Ophélie Winter
tout ça pourquoi parce qu'il me trouve
pas sympathique il me trouve rasoir il
me trouve ennuyeux c'est pas drôle enfin
voilà et puis j'organise des événements
pas sympa d'accord donc l'ensemble de
tout ça ils ont ils viennent et pourquoi
j'ai jamais été invité moi
si c'est pas payé je viens pas
voilà pourquoi tu es pas venu alors vous
allez aussi des activités dans les
médias presque télévision des livres en
96 vous avez publié politesse oblige à
l'archipel et aujourd'hui vous publiez
un autre bouquin c'est comment on fait
alors ça s'appelle un jour mon prince
viendra mais où quand et comment la
nouvelle regarde
voilà c'est chez Michel Lafont alors
c'est un guide pour savoir piégé le mari
idéal ah non là vous exagérez
pas du tout j'espère que les filles
elles doivent être un peu mignonnes un
peu sexy si elles veulent trouver un
homme et de ne pas rester chez elle
je reviens dans 2 minutes j'ai une
droite à lui mettre
du karaté
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas pourquoi mais je disais pas
ça pour toi
elle va te croquer mon garçon tu vas pas
faire moi demain
[Applaudissements]
me dites pas que c'est pas un livre pour
trouver le marin idéal
à éviter il y a toute une catégorie de
mecs qu'il faut éviter si on lit la
liste des mecs que vous suggérez
d'éviter je crois pas comment les filles
peuvent retrouver à moi personnellement
j'explique par exemple il y a le
maniaco-dépressif c'est à dire le type
qui au bout de 10 minutes a expliqué son
problème avec sa mère toutes les nanas
qui l'ont largué son problème de je sais
pas quoi de sport dans le boulot ça fait
deux heures cinq il y a l'autre qui vous
explique qu'il a séduit les plus belles
les plus sexy pendant qu'il vous parle
il a balayé tout le restaurant il a maté
tous les plus beaux culs et il a à peine
regardé enfin non il y en a il y en a
qui il faut éviter
de de temps en temps je parle un peu de
moi aussi dites-moi alors non alors la
séduction que faut-il faire que faut-il
ne pas faire par exemple mais donner des
conseils aux gens moi je pense que c'est
utile et tout ça il faut se mettre en
valeur il faut il faut sortir de chez
soi
nous je vous laisserai le bouquin après
je vous jure
j'aimerais bien ce qu'il faut pas aimer
extraordinaire
et quoi y faire
après c'est faire durer faire durer le
couple c'est important normal
qu'est-ce que vous croyez quand vous
draguez une fille vous faites des
efforts vous n'êtes pas comme ça toute
la journée avec la première femme que
vous croisez dans la rue vous serez pas
toutes des fleurs un dîner du champagne
vous faites un effort donc si vous
voulez que ça dure si vous aimez votre
femme et que vous voulez avoir une vie
de famille un peu sympathique et des
enfants et voilà une
grandisse dans de l'amour plutôt que
vous déchirez ou vous engueuler vous
faites un petit effort des deux côtés
c'est là où il y a le problème en
général alors il y a savoir rompre ça
c'est très intéressant dans votre vie
comment rompre il faut être élégant
rompre avec élégante très important
est-ce qu'on peut avoir un exemple de
comment rompre avec élégance par exemple
j'aimerais bien savoir comment ça se
passe
avec des fleurs tu peux rompre avec une
lettre d'amour tu peux
double exemplaire et poster géant là non
votre finale il est très mauvais il y a
du boulot Hermine avec beaucoup
d'expérience
il exagère il exagère beaucoup le
monsieur au bout de la table alors vous
votre premier c'était un vieux de 30 ans
c'est le genre de mec que je détestais
ça quand j'étais petit parce que le mec
c'est celui qui avait la bagnole c'est
nous on avait juste un Solex le mec
il avait du pognon pour vous emmener au
restaurant pour vous amener en week-end
je détester ce genre de choses
les boutons sur la gueule il les avait
pas
le deuxième c'était assez pire c'est un
avocat qui avait 58 ans vous êtes pas un
peu gérontophile sur les bornes
ils sont passionnants
par rapport à vous quelle est la
différence il est plus à vous 13 comment
ça se passe avec lui alors maintenant
vous avez des crises mais je sais pas
parce que je lui ai donné il y a deux
trois jours
c'est à peu près ça
je crois
alors un jour mon frère mais où quand et
comment par Hermine de Clermont tonnerre
chez Michel Lafont
bon maintenant donc comme vous êtes une
experte on va faire une interview alerte
rose
[Applaudissements]
bien
Hermine vous êtes prêts le lieu idéal
pour faire l'amour il y a pas de l'idéal
c'est n'importe où n'importe où
n'importe quand comme des bêtes
vous avez besoin de faire l'amour pour
aimer ou d'aimer pour faire l'amour
alors demain pour faire l'amour
vous préférez un mec qui baise bien mais
qui infidèle ou un mec qui baise mal
mais qui est fidèle je déteste
l'infidélité je hais la fidélité
non non non non vous avez dit d'accord
que si j'étais amoureuse j'étais une
dingue super jalouse
ou non mais ça c'est différent
les yeux si vous êtes moins jalouses
vous non mais à trois tu
voulais dire
tous ensemble mais oui mais alors
peut-être que tu acceptes quelque chose
de différent c'est pas tu commences avec
un mec qui est que pour toi et je suis
sûr que tu l'aimes différemment si tu es
amoureuse d'un mec que pour toi mais
alors tu peux pas supporter qui mais
qu'il est même touché une autre fille
moi pour moi c'est dur
vous préférez avec votre mec vous quitte
pour un homme ou pour une femme pour une
femme pourquoi non moi jaloux
vous préférez être caressé par quelqu'un
qui vous répugne ou battu par quelqu'un
qui vous aime ni l'un ni l'autre
mais non non mais là je peux quand même
avoir non ni l'un ni l'autre je
comprends les bonnes soeurs
[Rires]
vous préférez un mec qui couche avec une
autre en pensant à vous ou un mec qui
couche avec vous en pensant à une autre
je préfère encore qu'il est la cruauté
de penser à quelqu'un d'autre mais ouais
non un traitable dans un coup vous
pensez qu'il faut tout se dire ou rien
savoir
le mec qui sait que c'est un jour il
vous dit ça il est mort
alors est-ce qu'on embrasser c'est
tromper
ça dépend des circonstances
vous embrasser quelqu'un ou un bon
copain ou un truc dans la rigolade
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu